good to see you while your thank you so
much for coming out to see this talk and
for coming to buy data in general it's
been a really cool conference so far I
hope you've enjoyed it
my name is Philip Symantec and I'm going
to talk to you today about connecting
Python with foreign languages a little
bit about myself before we get started
I'm a software developer I've been doing
it since maybe the 80s something like
that started off working mostly in C and
over time transitioned into different
languages and have spent the past maybe
nine years or so working almost
exclusively with Python but I still
sometimes dive into C and and other code
like that compiled code and I get to
work with a lot of different
technologies web technologies databases
etc etc I'm a freelancer so I get to
bounce around from company and a company
and work with lots of different projects
and situations which I like it keeps a
lot of variety in the job and makes
things interesting and so maybe I could
even work for one of you someday if
you'd like to get in touch with me my
email address is right up there
about the picture that you see up there
it actually has nothing to do with the
talk but it's a pretty visually boring
talk I like to use my own photography
and the talking and I don't have any
photographs that say array of integers
or Fortran compiler so I just use some
kind of random photos so I just threw
that out there to make it look pretty so
why do we want to talk about getting
Python to talk to these foreign
languages well it's one of Python
strengths is its ability to talk to C
and C++ and so forth and I imagine that
as largely data scientists that you're
interested sometimes in getting Python
to speed up and so you might want to use
some compiled code for that or oftimes
you might have maybe like a scientific
instrument that only speaks to C and
doesn't speak to Python and so you want
Python to be able to get to talk to C
for that reason so Python is actually
pretty good at this but you have a
number of options and also the options
have changed over the years what used to
be fashionable the way the good ways to
do this are not so good anymore there
are a lot of tools actually out there
now to make life a lot easier and so
that the things you may have known about
this five or ten years ago
are less applicable and so what I would
like to do is just provide some more
clarity about the situation and
hopefully give you a better roadmap or
some ideas about how you can go forward
with that all the choices make this a
little bit cloudy and mysterious which
is my excuse to throw in just one more
photograph it's actually people sin
walking into some clouds that's not a
scene from The Hobbit it's actually my
mom and brother in a rain forest in
Costa Rica and is maybe not a good
photograph because that was actually
pretty nice kind of cloudy and that kind
of cloudy I was talking about was bad
kind of cloudy so just forget about that
slide then so the road maps were going
forward I wanted to cover these topics
in the talk and like any good C
programmer I'm starting from zero by
monks in my accounting so the first
thing I want to cover is that's the
basic principles of how Python can talk
to C and why it's pretty easy for Python
to talk to C and also how those concepts
extend to Fortran and C++ and then also
talk about the three ways the three
options you have for getting Python to
talk to one of these foreign languages
when I say foreign languages by the way
I'm talking about the three I mentioned
there C Fortran and C++ it is worthy to
say so I'll call them foreign languages
and then I want to suggest some tools
that might you might want to use to do
this that will help you along your path
and I'm gonna try to leave about ten
minutes at the end for QA it might be a
little tight but of course I'll be here
at the conference we're gonna break for
lunch right after this so you can grab
me at lunch if you want to talk to me or
email me at the address which I'll show
again on the last slide so without
further ado then let's talk about
pythons see API so when I talk about
Python the Python that's been around for
a very long time and actually was the
only Python for a long time is written
in C in recent years people have come up
with some other Python implementations
like JSON you may have heard of is
Python written to run against the Java
Virtual Machine
there's also pi pi which is written in
its own particular language and has its
own pretty interesting features the
Python we're going to talk about today
is only the traditional mainstream
Python written in C the other stuff the
stuff I have to say today it doesn't
apply to these other pythons and if
you're not really sure which Python
you're using
you're using see pythons you definitely
have to go through some effort to use
the other pythons so this C Python has
at its core a C API and you might have
seen the api's before that expose maybe
some of the concepts you know in a
language or a package this isn't that
kind of C API this isn't some half-baked
C API this is a really full fledged AC
API that exposes all of pythons inner
concepts to anybody with a C compiler
it's actually the calls that Python
itself uses to run your Python script so
when you type run my script PI Python
parses that compiles it to bytecode and
then calls this C API to do all the
things that it needs to do create lists
and dictionaries and functions this API
is pretty stable obviously changes a bit
from version to version it's well
documented there's a bazillion examples
out there for it and so it's good to
know that API is there and I want to
show you an example of what this API
looks like so up at the top there we
have some Python code for creating a new
dictionary and then at the bottom we
have the more or less equivalent C API
function to do the same thing I don't
want to get too bogged down in the
details just to point out that that API
is there and to compare the two
obviously the bottom the code on the
bottom is much more verbose C involves a
whole lot more bookkeeping and memory
management and so so forth and it's also
worth pointing out that C is a
procedural language and Python is an
object-oriented language so you have to
do some work in C to represent objects
even though C doesn't really have the
object concept so the code at the bottom
I think anybody looking at that you
would you know compare the two and you
can see that the code on the bottom is
much more elegant and expressive and
readable some people for whatever reason
still prefer the code on the top I don't
know why there's just no accounting for
taste but that's what the C API looks
like it is pretty tedious to get code
done in the C API but you can certainly
do it I'm not really going to recommend
that you go out and learn the C API it's
interesting I wouldn't discourage you
from it but you don't actually have to
look at any of that if you
want to but it's really good to know
that it's there and to be aware of it
and to understand that that's how Python
gets a lot of a lot of its work done
when it's talking to foreign languages
so now that we know this that Python has
the C API underneath you can kind of
understand how it's easy for Python to
talk to see right that it it has the C
API so it's pretty easy to get to
compile your C code to talk to that API
so what about Fortran and C++ well
Fortran mapped to C reasonably well
because Fortran has a lot of the same
primitives right Fortran has integers
and floats and arrays and strings and
pointers and so forth as does C so
Fortran also has a concept called the
ISOC binding which was added to the
standard in 2003
I don't remember I'm not I'm not a
Fortran guy in particular but it the ISO
C binding helps Fortran code look even
more like C to the compiler which eases
the transition if you're trying to get
Python to talk to something you want
your Fortran code to look like C so it's
not too hard actually to get Python to
talk to Fortran C++ is kind of another
matter because C++ has of course the
basic C primitives but this stuff that
makes C++ interesting is all the other
stuff the objects the template library
that exceptions that it has and so forth
and so managing the c++ can be kind of
difficult because python of course is a
C API and you're trying to talk to an
object-oriented language that expose all
sorts of concepts that C doesn't know
about Python might understand objects
and exceptions but C doesn't so it's a
good bit more work to get Python to talk
to C++ but definitely possible so our
three choices then for getting Python to
talk to these foreign languages
is you can wrap code you can write an
extension or you can embed Python in an
existing executable and I will go over
what each of these mean but these are
really our only two only three choices
so wrapping is the most common option
for four people so wrapping is when you
take an existing library library that
already
works is written in say for instance see
and you want to expose what that library
has to offer it to Python so what you do
is you create a Python friendly layer or
wrapper or binding all of those terms
mean roughly the same for an existing
library you write some code that makes
the objects in this library or functions
in the library accessible to Python that
wrapper can be written in a number of
different languages can be written in
Python or in C and it has two jobs first
it wants to do a binary translation of
information so for instance if you have
a Python integer and you want to pass
that over to say your C library the
wrapper has to translate that Python
integer which is called a boxed integer
it's a special fairly complicated entity
over to C which has a very simple
concept of what an integer is similarly
when you pass information back it has to
be translated from a C concept to a
Python concept there a Fortran concept
to a Python concept the other job that
the wrapper has is an idiomatic
translation the binary translation is
maybe the harder part if you screw that
up that's where you get seg faults in
the idiomatic translation is really
optional and you it gives you a lot more
choices as to whether or not you want to
work with the the idioms of the
particular language so if you think
about you've got this core library
written maybe in C or something like
that and it's got a number of features a
really really thin wrapper is going to
wrap over that like saran wrap or if
you're from the UK cling film it's gonna
adhere to the surface and expose all the
bumps and crevices and nooks and
crannies and it's going to be very the
the features of the underlying library
are going to come through very clearly
in Python a thicker wrapper can actually
change the idiom to something from what
the core library is written in to
something more pythonic so if I could
give you an example of this if you look
at the code at the top there that's the
documentation for some imaginary library
and you can tell right away what the
underlying library is written in it's in
C++ because that's a C++ idiom coming
through into your Python code it's not
the end of the world you can use it it's
just not as nice the bottom version is
more pythonic example of the same code
and that means that the rapper author
took more time to write that rapper make
a nicer rapper didn't take a whole lot
more time but it's a difference
it's shows how that how the two
different idioms can be expressed in
Python and the bottom one is nicer
another diagram a diagrammatic way of
looking at this if that's even a word is
to show here how in this course II
library that I have maybe I don't know
20 functions and if you write a very
thin wrapper there's going to come
through one to one and be exposed into
Python without any sort of decoration or
fanciness a thicker wrapper might take
the time to translate those concepts
maybe even into object if you got twenty
functions the thicker wrapper might say
you know what I can group these into
three categories and express them as
objects which are much nicer to use in
Python or at least they take advantage
of some of pythons strengths so that's
the what a thicker wrapper could do for
you is make a nicer to use library
there's no right or wrong choice about a
thin or thick wrapper it depends on how
much time you want to spend using it
spend how much time you want to spend
writing it and how much time you'll
think of using it so wrapping is useful
when you have an existing library that
already works and you want to use it
from Python and you don't or for
whatever reason can't modify the
existing code you just want to wrap it
our second choice is writing an
extension library or an extension module
extending Python sounds like you might
be adding new keywords or syntax that's
not the case this is actually not that
fancy probably everybody in here has
written up Python module that they and
then import into their main code so you
say import my module and then you
through the my module namespace you have
access to all of my modules functions
and objects and so forth this is the
same concept you're just writing that
module in a language that's not Python
so you're writing it in C but after you
get done you build this module you can
import my module and it'll look just
like a Python written module the main
difference between this and wrapping are
the main differences is that generally
this library is only going to be
accessible to Python it's not going to
be accessible through C or C++ or
whatever some exceptions to that but
that's the general case and in addition
to an extended library as sort of
self-contained so if you imagine before
when I talked about the wrapper you have
a wrapper around a core library and if
you take away that core library if it
gets uninstalled or changed or deleted
or something the wrapper has nothing to
talk to so it will break whereas the an
extension library is self-contained it's
it's it's own little file it of course
talks to the operating system into
Python but it's it's an entity unto
itself so running an extension module is
useful when you need to features of a
foreign language like speed or as I said
before talking to a scientific
instrument or something like that
and you don't need your code to talk to
anything but Python the last topic or
the last way I wanted to talk about the
last technique for getting Python to
talk to foreign language code is by
embedding and embedding is an uncommon
option but it's an interesting one so
what it does is during the the linking
step when you're building your code it
actually pulls a Python interpreter into
your executable so say you have a C or
Fortran executable you link in a Python
interpreter and at some initialization
point in your code you initialize the
Python interpreter and then boom you
have a Python interpreter running in
your process space well why would you
want to do that we can call Python code
very efficiently and exchange data with
it you can also for instance from a C
program
shell out to Python and run a Python
script from the command line but that
takes a long time you have to invoke the
interpreter you have to process data
through standard and standard out this
is a technique that allows you to have a
price Python interpreter in the same
process space as your main code it's
useful when you want your foreign
language code to call Python so the
first two techniques I talked about
wrapping and extending an extension
library they allow python to talk to
foreign languages embedding does the
reverse it allows your foreign languages
to talk to python so it's also an
interesting to do if you have maybe a
really big application that wants a
scripting language in it you can
actually have pi
as a scripting language in your
application and talk to your native
objects pretty cool so as I said it's a
bit unusual but it's a it's a pretty
interesting option so those are the
three techniques the rapping writing and
extension module and embedding those are
the three techniques that you have for
getting Python to talk to foreign
language libraries I wanted to talk now
about some tools that can help you
execute whichever one of these steps is
appropriate for your use case so the
first tool I wanted to talk about is C
types
it's from the Python standard library so
I think some people might think of C
types as an unusual choice because it's
a really lightweight tool it doesn't do
a whole lot for you but one of the
things I like about it is that it's
accessible if you already have Python
installed you don't need a compiler you
don't need to install anything else it's
just right there and it's easy to
experiment with and I think that if
you're maybe just getting started and
you want to try out some some simple
code it's kind of fun to work with C
types and just to see what it's like to
write a C types interface to talk to a C
function or a Fortran function so the
idea is that C types gives you some
support for creating integers and
strings and whatnot that will be
acceptable to see that you can pass
directly to a c function and that c will
accept and also to interpret whatever C
or Fortran or what-have-you might pass
back to you one of the things that it
does not offer is any automation support
and by that I mean suppose you have a C
library with 500 functions in it
well writing the C type interface to
each one of these 500 functions is it
going to take you a long time it's going
to be really tedious and would probably
make C types not at all an option for
that so I found C types gen up there
that claims to automatically create C
types interfaces for you I haven't used
it but it looks like an interesting
option another knock against C types is
that it doesn't have any C++ support I
want to give a quick example of how C
types can talk to Fortran there's a very
simple hello world written up there
Fortran and down at the bottom you see
the c-types code that who you might call
that with you can see the Seaside's code
is a little gunky there you know you've
got to create a Python variable and then
a Fortran friendly variable that that
shadows the Python variable and when you
pass it you have to be careful to pass
by reference not by value because that's
how Fortran expects things to be passed
to it you can actually pass the five
directly by value if you want and then
Fortran will try to access the memory
location five which is unlikely to work
under any circumstances so I get a seg
fault usually here's a nicer example
based on the previous one with some
small modifications that's the ISO C
binding stuff that I mentioned earlier
it just gives some hints to the Fortran
compiler that says you know what
actually I want this passed by value as
a simple integer and then the c-types
code is a lot nicer you can just pass a
value directly by or passed your
variable directly by value so it depends
neither one of these is right or wrong
as you if you might want to write a
wrapper for your Fortran code or make
nicer Fortran code you can make your C
types code easier the last example I
want to show not to overdo C types here
but just a general concept that you
might run into when you're trying to
move variables around there's no this is
all Fortran code there's no C types up
here but it just shows a general concept
of what if you want to move some complex
numbers around well Fortran understands
complex numbers and Python understands
complex numbers
unfortunately the C types part in the
middle does not speak complex numbers so
in order to move complex numbers between
these two what you can do is split them
up into their real imaginary parts send
those arrays over to Fortran and then
the Fortran code will knit them back
together into complex numbers call this
function do something which we don't
know what it does it does some operation
on the complex numbers and then at the
end you stitch the real and imaginary
numbers back into complex that make them
accessible back into the Python code not
that exciting or sexy but it does give
you an idea that a little bit of
creativity might go a long way towards
making things
across these language barriers so that
was c-types is a good good thing to
start off with is a good simple tool to
try try things with some other tools
that are probably more robust and more
enterprise ready or whatever you want to
call that there's CF Fi which is a
third-party project that interprets see
declarations so you can give it a whole
header file and just say here go figure
out what interface I need for these for
these functions which is really nice
right because that means you're not
writing you're not writing these all by
yourself
one by one it doesn't support Fortran or
C++ unfortunately so it's good at C not
so much for anything else
there's also F 2 pi which used to be an
independent third-party project it has
since been subsumed into Fortran or into
dumb PI sorry about that
I looked over it I haven't used it
personally I looked over it and it seems
to have actually a really nice feature
set it looks like a very interesting
project and so I started googling around
for conversations to see what people
were saying about it and I found almost
no conversations whatsoever which really
surprised me and so my guess either is
either that it works so well that nobody
needs to talk about it or that nobody
uses it I hope it's to former because it
seems like a pretty neat project if
anybody has experience with that
personal experience good or bad I'd love
to hear from you in the Q&A section or
just at lunch or something so let's talk
about wrapping C++ because as I said
before C++ is a good bit more complex
and one of the main tools for wrapping
C++ is swag that you've probably heard
of before
swag stands for simplified wrapper and
interface generator and it can parse C
and C++ headers once again like C FF I
so you can take an existing project and
say hey swig here's my headers you go
figure it out you go build interfaces
for this as I said before C++ is a lot
more complicated than C and Fortran and
so there's a lot more things that can go
wrong swig has
domain-specific language that with which
it describes interfaces so you have
these interface files that swig creates
and if swig isn't entirely understanding
what you're trying to say or what your
classes are trying to do you can modify
these interface files to give swig some
more hints so I call swig ambitious
because what it tries to do is a lot it
says it claims that you can give it a
whole C++ project and it will figure out
your interfaces for you and build
wrappers and and hopefully you won't
need to touch them there's a lot of
magic involved there because it's
inferring things about your classes and
moving data back and forth across
interesting boundaries and is really
wonderful when it works because it saves
you so much work however it's also a
little dangerous because it has to make
some assumptions that are not
necessarily entirely clear and for
instance there's some memory management
differences the C++ is a language it
works with explicit allocation and
delete setting aside smart pointers for
the moment in in C++ you allocate and
free things explicitly Python is garbage
collected I thought no it has no
explicit allergen-free
and so you can run into problems where
swig is trying to figure out how it
needs to deallocate objects and not
leave them hanging around in memory and
if it gets those guesses wrong you got
some weird seg fault when you access
some memory that's been released when it
shouldn't have been that can be pretty
hard to debug and that means you have to
dig into Suites interfaces and that can
get a little messy so I think this wig
is good for getting you a lot of the way
they are quickly but finishing that last
chunk to make everything perfect and
beautiful can be kind of time-consuming
because it's a little difficult to debug
it's really a really great choice for
large C++ projects because there's
nothing else that I'm aware of that can
get you started as quickly another
option for a wrapping C++ that I feel
like I really have to mention is boost
dot Python I haven't used this either I
did I think I helped rip it out of one
project
boost up Python seems to have a lot less
traction than swag for whatever reason
and when I googled around to see what
people were saying about it what I found
there's a lot of people that kind of
dismissed it too hard too difficult but
it had a number of people that were
really just had glowing reports about
boost up Python and some really ardent
admirers and I felt like it would be
giving it short shrift if I didn't at
least acknowledge it and say that it's
out there and for some people it seems
to be fantastic
my guess is those people are really good
at C++ and can appreciate what boost up
Python has to offer so the last thing I
want to talk about is scythe on and
maybe some of you who know this face a
little bit have been wondering when I
would get to this the reason that I
saved it until last is because talking
about everything else before this makes
it easier to explain scythe on and
describe what it does so scythe on is
both a project and a language the I
think the project appreciated the
language the language is actually 99%
like Python or 2 it attempts to be a
perfect superset of Python it's not
quite it supports almost all a Python
probably all the Python you're going to
use and it actually adds on some extra
see like key words to help you give
hints to the compiler as to what your
code is doing and that can add a lot of
speed to it so I call it Python with C
sauce scythe on is really versatile it
can help you with wrapping it can help
you with writing an extension module and
it can help you with embedding your code
it's the only tool that I'm aware of
that can do it can do even even two of
these let alone all three of them so
it's really powerful that way it's also
really nice to work with if you're new
to it because it can take straight
Python code as its input and what it
does is you give it Python code or
slightly modified Python code that has
become syphon code and it compiles it
parses your code and compiles it
quote-unquote to see so the output file
of the first scythe on process is a C
file and then you compile that C file in
a regular old C compiler and then you
have more or less Python code running
big speed boost running closer to the
executable speed of C and the the nice
thing is a scythe on can of course do
all this in one step for you if you like
and what it's using is you remember that
C API that we talked about on slide four
where wherever that was
that's what scythe on is doing is
cooking your Python code down to that C
API and then compiling that C API
directly so scythe on has some other
nice features is that it knows about
numpy because it news is that its target
audience is probably folks like you who
are doing a lot of numeric code and
without being able to talk to numpy it
would be not such a useful tool so it
has support in there for numpy it also
has decent C++ support allowing you to
move objects across the foreign language
boundary in addition I wanted to talk
about Fortran because that's part of the
topic here and Fortran 90 org has a
really nice tutorial on getting scythe
on to talk to Fortran so that's really
helpful to have out there for you
Fortran folks in the audience so one of
the knocks against scythe on is that
there is no automated interface
generation so I mentioned before about a
couple of tools CF Fi and swig can both
take a big batch of header files and
build a build interfaces for you so if
you have that function or that library I
mentioned before that has 500 functions
in it you don't want after hand write
interfaces to each one of them so that's
something that the other tools have that
scythe on does not have yet there is a
project out there called extras that
attempts to do this very thing to build
automated interfaces for you using
scythe on extras has been when I last
checked maybe a week ago has been has
had no activity for about one year I
think almost to the day like one year in
a day or something like that so it's at
that phase of projects where it's had
some interest in energy and now it's
starting to fade and get a little dusty
not at all too late for it to be rescued
and the good news is is that the author
is right here at this very conference
dr. Anthony Scott's he is giving a
keynote so if you're interested in
siphon and generating automated
interfaces here's your opportunity
yes you got to talk to him before after
his keynote maybe even during his
keynote just interrupt with a question
about extra s I'm sure he'd appreciate
that
so I think we are about out of slides
and that's fine because I wanted to
leave time for Q&A here so let me go
over what I just talked about so see
python has that C API and even if you
don't use it directly or personally it's
good to be aware that it's there and
what it's doing for you and how much it
can do so even if you don't use it
directly it's there and it's your friend
the three options you have for getting
Python to talk to foreign language code
are wrapping writing an extension
library and embedding all of these can
be done without any tools other than a
text editor and a compiler you can do
all these by hand with the C API if you
want and for many years that was how
people did things so you don't need any
tools but man they sure help a lot they
can save you an awful lot of time and
they can save you from digging around in
that grungy C API that we looked at
before and then the last point I want to
make about from the tools section is
that psyphon is so versatile that no
matter what you're considering doing it
really at least ought to be in your list
of candidate tools that you're
considering in some cases you can argue
that other tools like for instance maybe
swig would be better for you at getting
you started but one of the nice things
about scythe on is because it's so
versatile the time you spend learning
how to use scythe on to say wrap an
existing library well later when you go
to use scythe on to write an extension
module so an investment in scythe on is
likely to pay off over and over again
down the road so that was about all I
had I wanted to show you one more a
lovely picture that has nothing to do
with the talk and thank you I'd like to
thank each and every one of you but
there's not time so just say thank you
and thanks to our hosts here at PI data
and I did manage to leave about nine
minutes for Q&A so if anybody has
questions the man with the microphone is
over there and it looks like we have a
gentleman in the front here you're just
asking for a comment on 2pi so that's
not a question but the reason it's not
used is because it refers to a version
of Fortran that is not widely available
or used anymore it's quite ancient tool
and it does [ __ ] with numpy it needs
some love and needs a champion is what
it run needs and so perhaps that janitor
needs an ass there's an opportunity all
right looking for a champion no no no we
have a volunteer wonderful thank you
that was easy
champion volunteer I'm gonna have to
pass on that one um I have a question
which is what about you have any comment
about you know everything you've said
and rapping along with other high level
languages so like let's say you're
working with Python and R and not just
going up to Python but going up to other
high level languages do you have any
comments or experience on that I
honestly do not you caught me
flat-footed
I really don't I don't know enough about
or to really comment on that I know that
swig has a lot of facilities for
producing wrappers for languages other
than Python and that might be able to
help you out but no I really can't
answer your question I think mark might
be able to know you just had you have a
question to ask
Erik the gentleman in the front here has
a question sorry I couldn't answer that
a little bit better our part of the
interface problems you're talking about
marshalling back and forth data simple
like an integer does it include the the
byte order a low low order byte first
high order byte for first or is it just
that much more complicated no it does
the moving simple things back and forth
like integers are generally not a
problem it's well say if you're talking
to Fortran you have to
be aware that for instance its arrays
are column-major instead of row-major
and and things like that and strings are
terminated differently and so forth and
then it gets even more complex of course
when you're talking about C++ and moving
objects around so no byte order is not a
problem sometimes size of an integer of
32 versus 64 a bit the first Fortran
example I showed up there was really
sloppy and made some assumptions about
sizes of integers and let's try it out
it might work if you get a segfault then
whoops
you know maybe need to investigate but
yeah it partly depends on what you're
trying to pass across and what you're
wrapping it's complicated as you go up
gentlemen and then I saw this guy first
I'm not sure who so tell me about
deploying stuff you've written with
scythe on basically because it seems a
little complicated it's got to go
through a multi-step process can someone
come along and like pip install
something that was written using scythe
on yes and so it's a really interesting
question about deployment the good news
is that Python wheels have rescued us
from a lot of deployment problems so you
can deploy binaries much more easily and
it's a bit more complicated if you're
trying to pass along scythe on C code so
one of the really nice things about
scythe on is that if you have a C
compiler already installed you can write
your setup PI to accept scythe on C
files no get compiled on-the-fly pretty
easily with not much fuss to the user
it's a lot harder if you're deploying to
say for instance Windows where people
don't tend to have a compiler installed
and it's a big project for them to get
one if you're deploying to say a Linux
environment where you know there's
compilers readily accessible deploying
scythe on even if it's not precompiled
is pretty easy
was there another question out there
there was a hand up there somewhere hey
for the embedded side
how do external packages work so if you
if you were to embed a Python
interpreter how do you natively get the
you know num num PI and pandas and all
that other stuff is that an easy process
or is it a manual um it's it's easy once
you do things right so what at the
beginning when you initialize Python you
tell Python where it can find its
libraries and so it you need to provide
in addition to your embedded Python the
Python standard library because of
course a lot of python is implemented in
python itself and so just embedding a
Python interpreter into your executable
doesn't actually get you fully fledged
Python you have to provide the Python
runtime library and also the Python
standard library and in with that
standard library then you can supply all
the other good things that usually find
inside packages numpy and whatever you
like but yeah so it can be a little bit
of an adventure trying to get embedded
Python to find the right libraries but
once you do it you're good to go a good
question well I guess there were maybe
no more questions or comments so I just
want to thank you all very much again
and if you have any questions for me
maybe I'll see you at lunch so thanks
again enjoy the rest of the conference